[Music]
chris pratt
is wearing a shirt that people are
calling racist okay
now probably a lot of you people you
people have seen it
but if i were to tell you if you hadn't
seen an hour ago
chris pratt was caught wearing a racist
shirt what would you think he was
wearing like i mean i know you know what
it is but if you have
if somebody were to go hey man chris
pratt was caught wearing a racist shirt
what would you think he was wearing i
would think he was wearing not a shirt
but the sandwich sign that bruce willis
had to wear
in the third die hard movie god it was a
great scene
[ __ ] great scene yeah something like
that maybe
um this was the shirt that chris pratt
was wearing
uh by the way you could tell not making
a guardians movie for a little bit
because he's got a belly chris probably
oh homie does have a little good for him
though
you know what though homie's enjoying a
lot of summer cookouts
for him no yeah but you know he'll be
back in shape
to be star-lording coming back he's like
hey what's up guys it's just funny that
like hey look
again good for him that he he's willing
to go like oh yeah no it's a summer i'm
not working on anything
i'm gonna go i'm gonna eat two hot dogs
chris pratt is facing criticism over a
t-shirt he was pictured and wearing
featuring a controversial symbol
the marvel star controversial symbol
american flag that says don't tread on
yeah with the gadsden
right the writing and snake combo on
is this is depicted on the uh gladstone
flag a symbol created by christopher
glassen at charleston board
brigader general and the continental
army it came to
prominence during the revolutionary war
yeah the gadsden flag is
like the libertarian i mean this is like
the whole thing with the
please no step on snake oh no no no but
get ready we get no steps get ready for
get ready for this mental gymnastics
coming in you're going to love this
although the symbol has a non-racial
history
that's right right there that just
describes it right there it has been
used by the us men's soccer team at
metallica over the years
it has also been
adopted by political parties like the
tea party
and some libertarian groups as well as
gun-toting supporters of the second
amendment
uh it has therefore all listen to this
who wrote this
hold on this is from yahoo entertainment
hold on but that
but let me read the next line you you
read you heard everything i said
it has therefore also become a symbol of
more conservative and far-right
individuals
dude
the stretching that they have to do and
the problems you see that the problem
too is that they convect
so much that normies are now starting to
be like
shut the [ __ ] up shut up
just shut up enough enough i think
normal people are starting to really
i mean the ratings prove it the wrong
things just prove how people perceive
these idiots that write these [ __ ]
click bait yeah some people could
perceive it
even though it doesn't have this thing
some people think it has this
thing anyway that was your news for
today it's funny you said that dude i'm
not mike hasn't read this i'm going to
read the next line
it's why some people are critical of
pratt wearing a t-shirt featuring the
flag
many have posted their feelings about it
on twitter such as
tim byron's uh i like him
but all these small things about his
politics
make me wonder when he'll say something
transphobic
tank his career and do a feel he'll turn
and turn into a fox commentator
this is what royce just said
this is this is how the left thinks this
is how leftists think
i'm i'm such a [ __ ] complete
like nervous wreck i'm i'm such a train
wreck of a person
that it's not outside the realm of
possibility i could i could picture
royce somebody i could see that being a
thing that happens
but clearly because my crazy paranoid
mind is making that up
royce is the problem we need to cancel
royce by the way the thing things about
his politics you want
chris pratt has never mentioned what
political affiliation he has he's never
mentioned it
things about his politics that people
don't like is that he goes to church
well you know royce sometimes your your
politics and the way you are it really
makes me wonder when you're gonna [ __ ]
it really makes me wonder when that's
because i'm wondering that something's
wrong with you
no no i said i'm not don't worry about
it um
they don't eat the babies they just suck
they're sorry
uh so this is this is from him let's
read another one
ellen page called him out and some of
y'all didn't listen now look at this
[ __ ]
all right well ellen page also has a
face like viggo the carpathian now her
forehead
is getting out [ __ ] max headroom yeah
tell ellen [ __ ] quentin tarantino
paige
that uh i don't give a [ __ ] what she
thinks yeah nobody cares what you think
yeah nobody
nobody has ever said hey do me a favor
get me a react quote from the angry
i don't know i don't know what this
person is going to say but i kind of
like to try
areola grande areola grande is a great
name
unfollowed already haven't liked him
since parks and rec anyhow
and i could easily cancel him too uh
then they tap him
hope to see those bigots pay you a good
paycheck bye girl
for wearing a i love by the way i love
that gay people now they're things by
girl and you're like that's fine i don't
identify as a girl so that's different
that's your bigot you're being a bigot
um yeah this is it and by when they say
things about his politics because he
goes to church
because he thanked god like that those
are the things about his politics that
they don't yeah you know what i know
about chris pratt's politics
not much because unlike you he keeps it
to himself
yes you're right i know everything about
what all you people want with
[ __ ] you know pumping kids with
hormones
but i don't know what chris pratt's
really thinking other than he seems to
he seems to think america is okay yeah
and he seems to think jesus is kind of
an all right fella
that's literally he hasn't even gone so
crazy with any of those things that you
have to worry
he just seems like a guy that's like
yeah america's kind of cool
church is cool dude sometimes they do
like bake sales this helps me out
you know it's just nice everybody's nice
it's nice
he also the other part of his politics i
don't like is he loves his kids
um i noticed that they're all though no
none of them are really
you know they're worried about chris
pratt because he goes to church but
they're not calling out everybody that
went to [ __ ]
that's on [ __ ] jeffrey epstein's
flight manifest no no they're fine no
no they're fine somebody said eminem was
on there can anyone
cooperate that i don't know if that's
true or not that he was
on the uh that he was on the flights
maybe i saw that i see then again i i
gotta say this this is something that
probably should be said i don't think
every person that's gone to his island
is
you know what i mean 100 i agree so
100 agreed because that island was also
used
for you know meeting places for people
to have like and
and of course you would want to say
things like yeah you know eminem was
here last time
it was pretty cool yeah it's it's that
kind of thing too i know 100
of the people that went to that island
didn't
but the ones that went like 27 times
they were probably
for president clinton uh were probably
the guys that were there once like yeah
i don't know they just said i could come
for free